[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
the murder trial of derrick chauvin
charged in the death of george floyd
is underway from the prosecution in your
custody
is in your care to the defense the
evidence is far greater
than nine minutes and 29 seconds to
george floyd's family as they take a
knee in his memory
no justice no peace everything you need
to know about opening statements and
testimony
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to long crime
daily i'm jesse weber in for brian
buckmeyer who's in minneapolis right now
and of course terry austin is here as
well
opening statements in the murder trial
of derrick shovin the man
charged in the death of george floyd
let's break it all down
so derek shoven is facing three charges
second degree murder
second degree manslaughter and third
degree murder
he faces up to 40 years in prison if
convicted
14 people make up the jury 12 members
plus two alternates that's nine women
and
five men they will hear the case 15
people were selected but one was
dismissed monday due to
the size limitations of the courtroom
for coven 19 precautions
prosecutors say chauvin kneeled on
floyd's neck for nine minutes and 29
seconds that's nearly 45 seconds longer
than previously reported on may 25th
of 2020 mr derrick chavin
betrayed this badge
when he used excessive and unreasonable
force
upon the body of mr george floyd
it was about a counterfeit 20 bill used
at a convenience store
that's all you will not hear any
evidence that mr floyd knew that it was
fake or did it on purpose
i need to tell you ahead ahead of time
that the
video is graphic that it can be
difficult
to watch it is simply the nature of what
we're dealing with in this trial ladies
and gentlemen
you're going to see these bystanders a
very a veritable bouquet of humanity
these bystanders
929 the three most important numbers in
the case 9 minutes and 29 seconds
is how long that went on for half of
that time mr floyd was
unconscious breathless pulseless and
you'll be able to see
the uncontrollable shaking he's doing
when he's not breathing anymore
the anoxic seizures from oxygen
deprivation
you'll be able to see when he's going
through agonal breathing
the involuntary gasping of the body once
the heart has stopped
from oxygen deficiency we're going to
ask at the end of this case
that you find mr chavin guilty for his
excessive use of force against george
floyd
that was an assault that contributed
taking this life
and for engaging in imminently dangerous
behavior putting the knee on the neck
the knee on the back for nine minutes
and 29 seconds without regard for mr
floyd's life
long crimes and jeannette levy's here to
break down the defense's
version of events jesse the defense is
arguing that george floyd's death was
not a murder therefore derek chovin
in their words didn't commit a crime
a reasonable doubt is a doubt that is
based upon reason
and common sense derek chauvin's defense
attorney told jurors why they will find
out in the state's case eric nelson said
despite the hundreds of witnesses
interviewed by state agents the evidence
comes from four places
cup foods mercedes-benz
squad 320 and hennepin county medical
center
a cup foods clerk called reporting a man
who appeared to be drunk
bought cigarettes with a counterfeit
20-dollar bill and twice refused to
return them
police found george floyd in the
driver's seat of the mercedes-benz
which nelson said had pills containing
fentanyl and methamphetamine
floyd's friends shawanda hill and
maurice hall were in that suv
mr floyd's friends will explain that mr
floyd fell asleep
in the car and that they couldn't wake
him up that they kept
trying to wake him up to get going that
they thought the police might be coming
because now the store was coming out
nelson says floyd consumed pills to hide
them
and two containing floyd's dna were
found months later in squad 320.
nelson says the officer struggled with
floyd in that vehicle
leading to the infamous video of chauvin
kneeling on floyd's neck
you will see that three minneapolis
police officers
could not overcome the strength of mr
floyd
mr shelvin stands five foot nine one
hundred and forty pounds
mr floyd is six three weighs 223 pounds
nelson says chauvin followed his
training and did not
cause george floyd to die the evidence
will show
that mr floyd died of a cardiac
arrhythmia
that occurred as a result of
hypertension his coronary disease
the ingestion of methamphetamine and
fentanyl
and the adrenaline throwing flowing
through his body
all of which acted to further compromise
an already compromised heart
the defense opening just lasted about 24
minutes there was no mention
of that 2019 arrest video of george
floyd that judge cahill is allowing the
defense to show portions of
to the jury so really a low-key opening
statement from the defense
jesse all right thanks angela let's get
into this right now because brian i want
to start one of the things that came out
was the difference between cause of
death and
manner of death how did the state and
the defense handle that
yeah so cause of death is basically an
explanation of
what occurred uh cause of death could be
a bullet to the head a
punch to the heart and your heart stops
beating uh manner of death there's a
very limited
number of manners of death homicide
accident
natural suicide or undetermined now
when you put the conclusion of homicide
you're meaning
that that person's death regardless of
what or if
happened was done by another now the
prosecution addressed
both the cause of death and the manner
of death the defense
only addressed one and didn't address
the manner of death which i think is
the hardest hurdle for them in this case
and terry speaking of the defense they
almost seem to suggest that chauvin and
the officers were distracted
by the crowd that was gathering and
becoming more hostile what were your
thoughts on that
you know i think up until that point
eric nelson did a really
nice job i mean what could he say and he
said what he could say
he said it's more than the 9 29 seconds
it's more than just
50 000 bait stamps and 400 witnesses and
he did try to say
that the cause of death had to do with
his poor heart condition and with drugs
but when he
got to the point where he was talking
about the
crowd and the growing bystanders that
that was a distraction from the
care of derek you know of uh
george floyd that really really made me
blister i thought to myself how could he
possibly say that and i really do think
that the jury is not going to like that
either and angela let's talk about the
cause of death because the cause of
death is going to be disputed in this
trial and it appears that the county
medical examiner typically a prosecution
prosecution witness might actually
benefit the defense
yeah and i think that the defense is
really going to seize on some of the
things that dr andrew baker
the medical examiner of hennepin county
told the investigators in the beginning
of this case there are some case notes
in which he told them
that if george floyd had died at home he
would have classified his death as a
fentanyl
overdose a drug overdose so i really
think that they're going to seize on
some of what he said
and talk with him about that in his
testimony and he
eric nelson in his opening also
mentioned that the state basically went
shopping for
other experts to support their version
of events that
this was caused by the police officers
the cause of death is so critical in
this case and everybody's waiting for
mr baker to take the stand and explain
his rationale both
on the prosecution and the defense's
side so it's definitely going to be
something that we're going to watch
now still ahead on law and crime daily
george floyd's family taking a stand by
taking a knee
you're going to hear what they want out
of this trial
but first inside the courtroom and a
look at the first witness call
in the derrick chauvin trial what she
saw the day of george floyd's death
[Music]
next
and welcome back everybody the first
witness called in the derek chauvin
trial was the 911 dispatcher
who watched the cop kneeling on george
floyd's neck through the city's security
footage system
now she alerted her supervisor to what
she was seeing
i didn't know you can call me a snitch
if you want to but we have the cameras
up for
320's call oh did they already put him
in the they must have already started
moving him
um and 320 over at cup
foods okay um i don't know if they had
used force or not they got something out
of the back of the squad and all of them
sat on this man
so i don't know if they needed you or
not but they haven't said anything to me
yet
yeah they don't say anything unless
they're just a takedown which doesn't
count but
okay i'll find out no problem we don't
get to ever see it so when we see it
we're just like well
uh well you use the term snitch
yes what did you mean by that at that
moment it was a word that just came out
of my mouth
but it's out of the scope of my duties
to call a sergeant if
there was any use of words and so that's
what the purpose well tell me what was
the purpose
of making that call to him and giving
him that information
voicing my concerns like i said we don't
see incidents my job is
mainly all listening
now on cross defense attorney eric
nelson pressed scary on
how much she was actually watching the
video
you were still watching your rest of
your work right
correct i was actively still working so
you're look up for a couple seconds look
down
do your work look up look down from time
to time throughout the course of this
incident you're correct
all right and so it's fair to say that
your attention wasn't necessarily
focused
directly on the cameras and what you
were seeing
correct and you but it was concerning
enough to you
what you did see that you called
sergeant fluger
of the minneapolis police department
third precinct right
i was concerned yes because of the time
of the length of the incident had not
changed let's get into that brian
there was some extensive
cross-examination by the defense of this
dispatcher
where exactly was nelson headed there
so i don't it wasn't very apparent on
its face i think he might be using more
information
down the road of summation but i think
he was trying to show that she was
distracted
that she maybe wasn't focusing as
clearly as she was testifying to
but i think on the rebuttal by the
prosecution the thing that i liked
is that they pointed out this woman has
had six years of experience to that date
of when
derek chovin put his knee upon george
neck and she has the ability to focus on
multiple things just like jessie
you have the ability to speak with me
and hear our producers and hear the
audio and hear everyone in your
background but still do a great job just
like this woman did
well compliments are always well taken
thank you brian for that but
i'll tell you what was interesting terry
because she made a comment that you know
her
feed looked frozen i thought that was
very powerful giving an idea of what she
was looking at
and then everybody was wondering why did
the state call the dispatcher as the
first
witness why do you think that is you
know i think it was a powerful statement
and i think it was a testament as to
just
how long tobin's knee was on floyd's
neck
and i think he called the 9-1-1
dispatcher
first because he wanted to show that the
behavior of the officer
was so unusual and she felt the need to
call the sergeant and she had not done
that before
and this was the commanding officer so
i think she said her intuition told her
something was wrong and she wanted
someone else to know about it
and one of the things that bothered me
about the response was
i thought the sergeant was very cavalier
about what she was saying and
i wasn't quite sure whether he was going
to do anything about it i think it's
interesting to look at it now
back then and thinking maybe this one
comment that she's making little does
she know
what she's really looking at and where
it's going to lead a year later so it's
pretty incredible to hear that that
dispatch officer speaking with their
supervisor
all right coming up on law and crime
daily twin city residents are calling
for justice
in the name of george floyd we're going
to show you how some residents are
taking peaceful action
as derek shovin's trial begins
plus george floyd's family is speaking
out
we're going to tell you what floyd's
brother and nephew had to say
the night before the start of the
derrick chauvin trial people gathered in
support
of the george floyd family brian
buckmeyer was there for us and explains
what he saw brian
jesse people gathered at a church in
minneapolis on sunday
there was a call for action and justice
[Music]
prayers and support for the family of
george floyd fill the greater friendship
missionary church
this is george city because when you
think of joy
the service organized by the national
action network founded by reverend al
sharpton because this family will go
through a very painful
and very tumultuous
few weeks dozens attended offering
emotional support for anyone
needing it after watching the video of
floyd's death
is america prepared to hold police
accountable
and make them pay when they are wrong
attorney benjamin crump represents the
floyd family he says
they should be entitled to criminal
justice even after the 27 million dollar
settlement with the city of minneapolis
that many people have said river now if
the family gets
a civil justice then
they can't get criminal justice
well i don't know where that is written
that that
black people in america can't get whole
justice
that we can only get partial justice
krom pushing back
against what he called chauvin's defense
attempt to smear george floyd's name
by saying he was overdosed on fentanyl
what killed george floyd
was a overdose of excessive force yes
justice for you guys in terms of not
only a conviction but also potentially a
sentence
uh if and when trophies found guilty i
think that
uh we do not want to handicap to the
attorney general's office
about putting a bar in public but we
have clearly told him in private
with hope uh and when we say we are
talking about the family but i don't
think it's fair to give the defense
that uh the opportunity to say that
there's some kind of situation
that they could use against in that
trial and then i want to say this
attorney keith ellison and his team of
prosecutors
have worked with the family uh
throughout this whole journey
and we expect them to zealously
prosecute this case
and we expect them to do what is
appropriate
when we come back our exclusive
interview with the organization
paying for chauvin's defense the support
on the other side of the courtroom
stay with us
and welcome back everybody a police
organization in minnesota is paying for
derek chovin's defense
and jeannette levy spoke exclusively
with the head of the organization
about the support derrick chauvin is
receiving and jeanette
jesse you certainly don't see crowds of
people showing up at the courthouse in
minneapolis to support
derrick chauvin but there is support for
him you can see it online on social
media
and according to brian peters the head
of the minnesota police and peace
officers association
people have actually called and tried to
donate to his defense
there's some people that feel strongly
that derek strauben is
is being used by
organizations as a reason for whether
it's bringing police reform or
what have you or exposing you know
systematical racism
um anyway that has led to a lot of
people contacting our office
and taking donations and frankly um the
reason why
we didn't accept any donations is i i
don't know
where where the donations are coming
from
peter says they simply don't have the
time to vet the sources of these
donations
he said they more than likely went to
another organization or
organizations that take care of living
expenses for officers who may be
experiencing trouble
jesse all right thanks angenet george
floyd's family took a
strong stance in front of the courthouse
by kneeling on the ground for the same
amount of time
that chauvin kneeled on floyd's neck
we came in for one thing and one thing
only we came to get justice
and nothing less we came to get justice
so either they weren't trained and
qualified to do their job
or they intended on taking his life
either way
we need justice we're taking a knee
for eight minutes and 46 seconds and we
want you to think up during that time
why shaven didn't in that time
get his knee up
now brian there's going to be a lot of
activity we imagine outside of that
courthouse and do you anticipate that
what happens on the outside
is going to have an effect on what's
happening inside the courtroom and how
could judge cahill
prevent that from affecting the trial
i mean jesse i don't know how he is
going to prevent it
i think that you're going to see not
only outside the courthouse
there we're right now on the southeast
corner on the direct diagonal of us
there are people who are lightly
protesting i would say maybe 40 people
or so
stepping onto the streets causing
traffic to move around also there's a
protest earlier this morning
near the entrance way of where jurors
and other people are ushered into the
building
and so they're going to see that they're
going to hear that on the news how judge
kale
is going to stop them from doing that
and hearing that i'm not sure except for
admonishing them not to listen to the
news and other sources
fingers crossed that they actually you
know listen and are able to do that but
by all accounts you're hoping they will
uh
and jeanette it's interesting because
the organization
that's paying for the officers defense
they
see the case in a different light don't
they i mean can you exp
expand upon that yeah they see it in a
much different light jesse i think that
in talking to brian peters he's very
circumspect given the warnings that
judge cahill has given about these
comments outside of the courtroom
but he did say they feel strongly in the
case he believes there are facts about
police training and how much
force officers can use that will benefit
derek shovin along with information
that's in the medical examiner's report
terry we heard attorney ben crump who
represents george floyd's family say
that he refutes the idea
that this is a hard case do you agree
with him
you know what jesse i understand
completely why ben crump would say
that this is not a difficult case
there's a video
and it shows derek chovin kneeling on
george floyd's
you know neck and refusing to remove his
knee the prosecutor actually said that
chauvin does not
let up he does not get up even after
there's no pulse and even after the
ambulance
came he waited until the medical people
said to him
to get up so you know the job of the
defense is to make this a little bit
more
complicated and what they're trying to
say is that the cause of death had
nothing to do with the knee that it was
the drugs in his system or his heart but
what ben crump and the family are trying
to say is
look if you look at this from a
humanitarian point of view
there's no question george floyd did not
have to die
that day he died because of the fact
that that knee was on his neck
and what's interesting is you're hearing
nelson saying that it's not only the
drugs
it's not only under underlying health
conditions but it's also the adrenaline
as well that culminated at that moment
it's going to be an interesting back and
forth between both sides
and anyway thanks for joining us here on
long crime daily we're going to see you
next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you